channing tatum in the lost city with
sandra bullock and only e.t can take you
behind the scenes on the very
picturesque dominican republic set
[Music]
living the dream
sandy b always takes us to the nicest
places
sandy thanks girl
a giant waterfall a luscious jungle and
live snakes
one snake scene down
sandra and channing really see it all in
the lost city she's a romance novelist
who is kidnapped while chanting as her
book cover model is on a mission to
rescue her and on set they had no fun at
all all right hands are so strong
why are you
straight like
the adventure comedy hitting theaters
next friday is sandra and channing's
first project together
i think it's very inspired by some of
those movies that are supposed to be
feel good movies but also be able to
keep the stakes and that's one thing
that i think that almost i don't think
anyone else in the industry does as well
as sandy does come on sandy that's good
yeah yeah
kidding
kidding just kidding it's so sweet
channing tatum brings to dash uh a gold
mine and then on top of it he's really
handsome he's got a six-pack
and i don't
so i'm glad one of us had it
uh and i'm glad he was willing to take
his shirt off and his pants um because i
wasn't
so that's what he brings to it
[Applause]
[Music]
you